close your eyes I rock off the tiny  piece of the Alps  get out here's what we're gonna do  you're gonna get off the couch and  you're gonna come to the gym with me no  I hate the gym you do not hate the gym  sorry Timmy to scare you or tray more  the trainer's here you look great good I  can't do this yes you can I don't wanna  hear that cuz you've done such a  tremendous job  I got you something it's a fitness  tracker you give me your phone I can set  it up for you do you see anything you  like absolutely so this date anything  serious moving a little fast no I think  when you see something you want go for  it right  super creepy and there are tons just  like this from the exact same number  who's yours  sometimes you hit a couple of unexpected  bumps on the road to success okay take  it very good  hello who is this it's me your secret  environment  on  I'll never let anything happened to you  ever  you